hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute lecker
rindergulasch und ich liebe das ich
freue mich immer wenn du es gibt wobei
ich mir nur selber koche aber ich freue
mich immer wenn es soweit ist und wir
machen das heute auf die klassische art
und ich zeige euch wie ihr euch das
fleisch richtig gut gelingt das ist
total zart und weich wird das ganze ist
auch gar nicht so schwer von der
zubereitung her und wir kommen erst mal
direkt zu den zutaten
wir benötigen natürlich rindergulasch
außerdem fein gehackte zwiebeln
rinderbrühe neutrales öl da habe ich so
einen rummel verwendet außerdem
tomatenmark edel süßes paprikapulver
hier habe ich noch fein gehackte
knoblauchzehen lorbeerblätter etwas
chili das schaf mag und natürlich salz
und pfeffer so das öl ist jetzt heiß
genug und jetzt nehmen wir uns unser
fleisch und hier müsst ihr besonders
aufpassen denn der trick ist dass ihr
das nicht übereinander reingeht das
heißt gerne in zwei oder drei schritten
anbraten ich mache das jetzt mit dem
hinten rein dann habe ich ein besseres
gefühl dafür und dann muss das erst mal
von einer seite anbraten und noch nicht
wenden
und wie gesagt das ist ganz wichtig dass
ihr das fleisch jetzt nicht schon wendet
mit eurem kochlöffel sondern lasst uns
erst mal ein paar minuten richtig schön
anbraten und erst dann lässt sich vom
topfboden ganz von alleine löst dann
könnt ihr das mit einem kochlöffel
einmal wenden
[Musik]
und sobald unser fleisch zumindest von
außen gar ist also von hinten alles
später noch da macht euch mal keine
sorgen nehmen wir das einmal aus dem
topf raus und dann beraten wir das
übliche fleisch an
[Musik]
so das fleisch ist jetzt fertig das gebe
ich jetzt kurz an die seite denn wir
machen weiter und zwar braucht ihr hier
kein zusätzliches fett ich habe jetzt
nur den herz runter gestellt auf
mittlerer stufe und gäbe da zwiebeln
rein und nach einer minute ungefähr
knoblauch und dann wird das schön
gedünstet
[Musik]
mit dem knoblauch zusammen dürfte das
ganze jetzt auch noch mal so ungefähr
zwei minuten langen dünsten und als
nächstes dem wie tomatenmark in zonen
arbeiten was richtig gut ein
sobald das ganze gut miteinander
verbunden ist geben wir unser edel süßes
paprikapulver und die chiliflocken dazu
und ich bin ja so ein weichei was
schärfer angeht deswegen habe ich hier
sehr wenig chemie aber ihr könnt
natürlich auch mehr nehmen und das ganze
wird jetzt ohne kerne halbe minute lang
richtig schon eingearbeitet und dann
geht's weiter
länger als eine halbe minute das ganz
aber nicht dauern sonst werden die
gewürze bitter und dann schmeckt nicht
mehr so gut und als nächstes wird das
ganze mit der im frühjahr ab
[Musik]
also ihr lieben als nächstes gehen wir
unser fleisch jetzt zurück in die brühe
und dann wird das kann zu ein mal
aufgekocht an der stelle könnt ihr auch
gerne schon euren lorbeerblätter
hinzugeben und dann auch gerne noch mal
mit salz und pfeffer abschmecken wobei
das natürlich gerne auch immer am
schluss
und bevor ich das vergesse den
ausgetretenen fleischsaft auf jeden fall
mit in den topf geben das habe ich hier
schon getan aber nicht dass es jemand
weg schritt in das gehört auf jeden fall
noch in den topf und jetzt wäre das
ganze abgedeckt und dann lassen wir das
köcheln auf niedrigster stufe wenn ihr
zum beispiel neuen stufen nach nimmt er
einfach stufe 2 und dann müssen wir
warten zwei stunden dann guckt mich
nicht so an das gehört sich so und
danach lohnt es sich das fleisch wird
richtig schön saftig und zart also wir
sehen uns in zwei stunden
so ihr lieben die zwei stunden sind rum
und will schon einmal in den topf und
das fleisch ist jetzt so richtig zeit
jetzt ist das ganze allerdings noch sehr
flüssig natürlich wer mag kann das jetzt
auch als suppe genießen aber ich sehe
mir das heute zu bandnudeln und deswegen
werde ich jetzt das ganze noch ein
bisschen an dicken mit wasser und mehl
und die wasser mehl mischung gebe ich
jetzt einfach noch mit in den topf und
lass es einmal aufkochen und dadurch
ständig umrühren
und zum schluss könnt ihr natürlich
gerne noch nachsalzen und nach pfeffern
und dann ist ein leckeres kolesch auch
schon fertig und ich sage euch es lohnt
sich diese wartezeit lohnt sich einfach
total weil das fleisch super zart ist
wir genießen das wie gesagt jetzt zu
nudeln ist passen aber auch zum beispiel
spätzle reißt alles eigentlich alles
worauf ihr lust habt ihr könnt natürlich
auch so essen ohne alles auch super
lecker und ich schreibe euch natürlich
wie immer die genauen mengenangaben hier
unten in die infobox ich freue mich wie
immer über eure fotos mit dem hashtag
wikis kitchen auf instagram ansonsten
hinterlasst diesem video gerne ein
bäumchen nach oben abonniert meinen kann
kostenlos beim verpasst ja auch nichts
mehr und dann sage ich bis zum nächsten
mal aufgelegte sketchen
[Musik]